chez nous voici donc cette semaine à
condé sur seul dans le calvados très
beau département surtout après le café
condé sur ce c'est un peu isolé bayod la
ville la plus proche est à 9 km aussi
monsieur et madame gauthier agriculteur
à la retraite utilise est il pour leurs
déplacements ces dernières années des
vélos solex n'ayant ni l'un ni l'autre
leur permis de conduire à ses 1 gauthier
bonjour alors voilà les très beaux vélos
solex que vous utilisiez bonjour
monsieur côté jardin pour aller à bayeux
oui voici cinq six ans et que vous avez
obligé de rembourser au solex là oui
parce que j'ai eu une opération est
alors j'aimerais plus en faire alors
vous avez demandé à votre pari de passer
son permis de conduire et oui alors par
quatre fois il a loupé semble alors
c'était bon aussi ou est ce que vous
étiez inscrits et approchez vous un
petit peu à l'auto école à bayeux oui le
tricole pourquoi vous ratez rien
sur les planches et moi j'ai vu j'ai
passé les oui et puis alors ça changeait
d'examinateurs à chaque fois vos goûts
le premier qui lui a fait passer qui lui
a fait passer l'examen
on connait c'est un peu et certainement
qu'il allait le prendre un deuxième
point deuxième autres aux allemands il
ya tombé malade entre dit ça et à chaque
fois vous deviez vous cherchez changer
les amis de cergy d'examinateurs à
chaque fois c'était du moteur un truc
qui vous dit ils voient tant leurs
traites rue alors ça doit être mes
chances
il faut poser comme question ça me
rappelle pour beaucoup que vous voudrez
truc vraiment vaches alors oui vraiment
difficile très difficile qui a priorité
à un croisement jeu comme ça oui il
fallait pour faire de foot du tout voilà
c'est impossible pratiquement alors ça
sort était toujours le même évidemment
vous l'auriez à la longue il aura eu
certainement dans des cra impossible oui
parce que jamais une fait défaut point
de vue code et tout ça voyez vous on n'a
jamais été pris en défaut avant quand on
sort donc un s'est le mieux vendu code
qr code
on recevait le fado avait à faire un
panneau rouge avec une barbe blanche au
milieu
c'est ce que c'est facile comme question
c'est pas facile
un panneau rouge oui avec un trait blanc
comme ça mais pêchaient être blanc selon
ralentir dans les virages tout ça oui
mais pas le permis non mais oui c'est
injuste c'est parfaitement injuste mais
heureusement il ya toujours une justice
et la méchanceté des examinateurs du
permis de conduire n'a pas empêché le
monsieur madame gauthier d'acheter une
voiture il s'agit ne superbe harold
qu'ils utilisent quotidiennement sur les
routes du calvados sans permis de
conduire et en restant pourtant
parfaitement dans le cadre de la
légalité comment font-ils
eh bien monsieur gauthier a trouvé le
truc il accrocher la ronde
autre acteur qui conduit depuis des
années il n'y a pas besoin de permis de
conduire pour piloter tracteurs et pour
la loire pour les gendarmes
la ronde est devenu une simple remorque
agricole
monsieur gauthier à sa voiture sans
avoir besoin de permis de conduire une
opération qui a coûté en tout et pour
tout à ronde du système de remorques 400
francs vous êtes bien la voir au plus
rester là vous êtes bien à l'abri comme
un coq en pâte leur propre besoin de se
casser la tête avec le volant ni rien
si encore après la l'intérieur vous en
servez vous êtes bien comme tout alors
voilà le la partie mécanique
oui d'installation qu'est ce que c'est
cette caisse ça sert à quoi la ambitieux
quand j'entends que tu cites nourrir je
raccompagne voilà la place du mot taya
du siège social de mal alors que disent
les gendarmes nigériens
quatre sites où pascal bien en plus
c'est que si vous avez une contravention
c'est pas vous qui l'aurait c'est madame
gauthier puisque c'est elle qui est dans
la voiture
eh oui
qu'importe vannes gauthier elle est
absolument ravis puisque grâce à linge
et vios trouvaille de son époux elle
peut faire en toute tranquillité ces
courses en voiture tracteurs remorques
dans les rues de beille
j'ai d'ailleurs pu me rendre mieux
compte encore des avantages du système
puisque monsieur gauthier a eu la
gentillesse de m'inviter à une promenade
dans son art ont d'abord tracteur
incroyable car comme ça et pas son
permis les wii sports parce que je vous
assure qu'en ville
jamais n'a coché une part mais on va
jusqu'à perrier dans la manche
taccoen qu'ils ressentent 10 km m
25 à penser changer de modèle bientôt oh
non que voulez vous encore dépenser de
l'argent pour voir or m d'ailleurs c'est
les voitures de maintenant non pas la
tôle à ses portes et vous savez
vous-même que ce soit quelque chose de
rustique pour pouvoir faire ça pour
pouvoir faire ça je n'ai pas vu une
voiture de sport pendant au moins trois
fois non décapotable non je me trouve
qu'il ya comme ça ça va évidemment il
subsiste un tout petit problème c'est
pour dire aux pilotes de s'arrêter
surtout quand il est un peu dur
d'oreille parce que si vous allez si
vous êtes prise d'un besoin pressant par
exemple ça ça peut prendre ses
précautions prend parti pour durer
dès que ce petit problème aura été
résolu
le système tracts aux mobiles côtier
deviendra idéal pour tous ceux qui
n'arrivent pas à obtenir leur permis de
conduire à cause de la méchanceté des
examinateurs